wir führen die kontrollierte abgabe von
cannabis an erwachsene zu genuss zwecken
in die zensierten geschäften ein so
steht es im neuen koalitionsvertrag
aber was heißt das für uns als
gesellschaft verspricht dafür was
spricht dagegen und was können wir von
anderen ländern lernen die cannabis
schon früher legalisiert haben ich bin
aminata berlin und heute setze ich die
legalisierung von cannabis für euch in
den kontext
[Musik]
das verhältnis von deutschland zu
cannabis ist seit anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts ambivalent cannabis führt
hierzulande das erste mal offiziell 1929
verboten ein ergebnis das 1925
verabschiedeten internationalen opium
abkommens obwohl hans ab da an
international geächtet ist hat die
hanfpflanze eine wichtige bedeutung im
zweiten weltkrieg forderte man die
bauern in einer so genannten lustigen
hand fibel sogar auf hanf anzubauen
kurz jede saat in hand fürs feld bringt
reiche ernten reiches geld der handvoll
baut mit fleißige hand hilft selbst sich
und dem vaterland baut hans
die seile und der stoff aus dem
wasserfesten starken fasern wurden für
die kriegsmaschinerie gebraucht
hitler selbst war aber kein käfer die
nazis inszenierten sich gerne als
abstinent des starkes volk dabei war bei
der wehrmacht zum beispiel pervitin eine
aufputsch troge vergleichbar mit crystal
meth im einsatz ausserdem spritzen sie
sich ein heroin ähnlichen stoff namens
euro da ein ganz ähnlicher ideologischer
trend ließ sich ab 1930 schon in usa
erkennen auch hier vertrat der chef des
us amerikanischen federal bureau of
narcotics harry ensslin die ideologie
eines abstinenten und starken
volksempfänger erklärte im kampf gegen
cannabis zu seiner lebensaufgabe und
setzt in den 1930 er jahren eine
hetzkampagne in gang dafür verwendet er
die mexikanischen namen verhalf
marihuana die anti marihuana kampagne
rollt auch in den medien an kino filme
zeigen die angeblichen folgen des
drogenkonsums
wesentlicher bestandteil der kampagne
war sein rassistisches gedankengut
er lächelte cannabis als droge von
mexikanern und afro amerikanern nach
ansicht eines lengers menschen zweiter
klasse
so behauptete etwa
der hauptgrund marihuana zu verbieten
ist ein effekt auf die degenerierten
raschen mit der unterstützung mächtiger
wirtschaftskonzerne die die hand pflanze
als konkurrent ihrer eigenen produkte
sahen verbotes länger die hanfpflanze
erst in den usa und schaffte es mit
seiner auffassung schließt sich sogar
bis zu den vereinten nationen von 1961
die single convention online cotic
trucks verabschiedet wurde sie
klassifiziert cannabis bis heute als
einer der gefährlichsten drogen der welt
das hatte in deutschland aber zunächst
nur wenig auswirkungen nur sieben jahre
später identifizierte und inszenierte
sich die 68er bewegung wie keine andere
generation in deutschland trotzdem mit
cannabis und qualmenden jones
1968 das jahr in dem sich so viel ändert
die jugend bricht aus erfindet sich neu
und ärgert das establishment mit musik
mit drogen und protesten vier jahre
später zog deutschland nach und übertrug
die internationale konvention
1972 in ein nationales gesetz das opium
gesetz von 1929 wurde zum
betäubungsmittelgesetz
das neue gesetz regelt den umgang mit
cannabis von nun an viel konkreter anbau
handel kauf und sogar der besitz von
cannabis sind von da an tabu aber ein
strenges verbot gegen drogen hielt die
leute natürlich nicht davon ab weiter zu
konsumieren
[Musik]
die polizei nimmt jetzt nicht mehr mut
dealer fest sondern auch konsumenten das
wird zum festen bestandteil der
polizeiarbeit doch dann mit der
neunzigerjahre regt sich gegen diese
praxis widerstand und zwar ausgerechnet
aus den reihen der justiz zwei monate
haft erhielt eine junge frau die ihrem
mann einen hash päckchen hier in lübeck
in die u-haft schmuggeln wollte inhalt
gut 1 gramm der software oder unsinn
sagten die richter der 2 kleinen
strafkammer des landgerichts lübeck und
setzten das verfahren in zweiter instanz
aus das betäubungsmittelgesetz verstoße
gegen das grundgesetz
sie leiten aus dem grundgesetz aber auch
ein recht auf rausch ab ist das richtig
das ist zutreffend sind auch der
überzeugung dass es zwar große probleme
geht im umgang mit raus aber das ist ein
teil menschlicher selbstbestimmung ist
schließlich nimmt sich sogar das
bundesverfassungsgericht dem thema an
und entscheidet der besitz von
geringeren mengen cannabis zum
eigengebrauch sollte nicht weiter
verfolgt werden das urteil hatte seine
fans aber auch seine kritik ein so ist
ein beschluss des
bundesverfassungsgerichts wohl noch nie
gefeiert worden mit veilchen und
marihuana zigarette happening im
englischen garten also klar muss sein
ist kann keine freigabe von drogen in
der bundesrepublik deutschland geben und
es kann auch nicht so sein dass die
strafbarkeit des umgangs mit drogen
aufgehoben wird im wesentlichen besteht
diese regelung von 1994 bis heute fort
der besitz geringer mengen zwischen
sechs und zehn gramm je nach bundesland
bleibt straffrei anbau und handel von
mariana aber nicht bis jetzt denn die
ampel koalition will das ändern
cannabis soll für erwachsene legalisiert
werden nach vier jahren soll das gesetz
überprüft werden auf gesellschaftliche
auswirkungen überfällig oder ein
dammbruch
droge ist ja klar aber dass man die ja
auch legalisieren muss oder zumindest
entkriminalisieren muss um die besser
regulieren zu können dass auch
minderjährige die nicht zu missbrauchen
eine generelle freigabe ist 55 endlich
schwierig denn wer wildes kontrollieren
und wo wollen sie die grenzen ziehen
zwischen
cannabis und und den anderen rauscht
roben es gibt also verschiedenen
perspektiven zu dem thema die einen
freuen sich darauf die anderen sehen es
eher kritisch aber was spricht denn nun
für eine liberalisierung von cannabis
und was dagegen hier sind die
wichtigsten argumente für eine freigabe
von cannabis erstens lizensiertes gras
würde nicht mal so viele schadstoffe
enthalten wie illegal verkaufte stoff da
es nach festgelegten qualitätsstandards
produziert werden soll illegaler stoff
ist nämlich häufig verunreinigt und kann
im schlimmsten fall zu
gesundheitsschäden führen was sind die
vorteile einer liberaleren drogen
politik wie sorgen sie bessere qualität
also ich muss mir nur vorstellen meine
kinder müssen auf dem schwarzmarkt
kaufen sich der um welche drogen die
völlig verunreinigt sind es viel besser
wenn sie saubere und ordentliche drogen
in der apotheke beziehen
herrsching bringt uns damit direkt zum
zweiten argument jugendliche werden
besser geschützt wenn gras nur noch in
lizensierten geschäften an vorjährige
abgegeben werden dürfte sagen dafür wird
der cannabis legalisierung drittens eine
legalisierung von gras würde finanzielle
und personelle kapazitäten bei der
polizei und justiz frei machen sagt zum
beispiel der jugendrichter andreas
müller das schon seit jahren für eine
entkriminalisierung von cannabis kämpft
wir haben nicht genügend richter nun
staatsanwälte und polizeibeamte jürgen
dörr den wird immer geschrieben ja wir
brauchen mehr polizeibeamte menschrechte
hört doch auf die täter zu verfolgen
ein weiterer vorteil den man sich von
einer legalisierung erhofft richtig wie
knete denn auf legale drogen kann man
steuern erheben so wie das auch schon
bei tabak und alkohol bereitschaft
arbeitsplätzen
kann man steuergruppe jedem und so
weiter und so fort also es wäre schon
nicht folgen und last but not least man
würde den anbau und handel von cannabis
aus den händen krimineller strukturen
nehmen argumentieren befürworter der
legalisierung warum lassen wir diese
substanzen in den händen von kriminellen
organisationen warum nimmt der staat
nicht die verantwortlichkeit von der
produktion bis zum detailhandel wenn man
so sagen können mit strengen regeln die
kritikerinnen und kritiker einer
liberalen drogenpolitik haben auch ihre
argumente wir schauen uns jetzt mal die
wichtigsten an erstens verweisen
skeptiker einer liberalen drogenpolitik
darauf und das cannabis eben droge ist
und bleibt mit gefährlichen auswirkungen
auf psyche und natürlich ist man die
frage ist ein
weitgehendes verbot
immer eine ursache auch von schwarzmarkt
das ist ein argument auf der anderen
seite durch eine legalisierung würde man
die schwelle noch weiter
heruntersetzen und wir halten doch die
nebenwirkungen von cannabis für so
gefährlich dass man das nicht tun sollte
nur weil alkohol gefährlich ist
unbestritten ist cannabis kein brokkoli
die angst der cannabis gegner durch eine
legalisierung könnte der konsum steigen
außerdem befürchten einige dass der
zugang zu cannabis für minderjährige
noch einfacher werden könnte als das
jetzt sowieso schon der fall ist und die
hemmschwelle fürs kiffen noch niedriger
wählen könnte würde in dem moment über
menschen die über 18 sind die es legal
erwerben könnten dann aber wir haben
natürlich konsumenten die sind deutlich
unter 18 jahre und die werden sich
wieder weiter mit raps markt bedient
werden können und hier dürfen wir mit
dem signal es ist harmlos es ist nicht
verboten dürfen wir nicht den falschen
weg bestreiten außerdem finden
kritikerin der cannabis legalisierung es
stimmt gar nicht dass durch eine
liberalisierung mehr kapazitäten bei
polizei und justiz frei werden würden im
gegenteil eine kontrollierte abgabe
bedeutet dass kontrolliert werden muss
mehr anders als die polizei sollte das
denn kontrollieren und vor allen dingen
ist damit das argument beispielsweise
von herrn lindner ad absurdum geführt
dass eine kontrollierte freigabe
ressourcen bei justiz und polizei
freisetze das ist nicht setzen wir uns
mal etwas genauer mit den pro und contra
argumenten auseinander immerhin sind wir
nicht die ersten die den handel von
cannabis legalisieren von den anderen
ländern können wir uns einiges abschauen
das prominenteste beispiel für eine
liberale drogenpolitik sind man kennt
die niederlande was meine diskussion um
die drogenpolitik bei unseren nachbarn
aber oft untergeht in den niederlanden
ist der besitz kauf bzw verkauf und die
produktion von cannabis tatsächlich
illegal lediglich der besitz von
kleineren mengen und übrigen auch von
fünf cannabis pflanzen wird dort
toleriert
das hat zu der entstehung von coffee
shops geführt in dem niederländer in
graz für sich selbst kaufen können diese
regelung geht in den niederlanden schon
seit mitte der 70er jahre die bilanz aus
dem nachbarland ist gemischt das
positive also das haben dann tatsächlich
in holland auch erlebt es gibt nicht die
erfahrung dass der konsum steigt das
bestätigt auch ein eu-bericht zur
drogenproblematik
analysiert wurde ob verbote oder
legalisierung 'nen den cannabis konsum
beeinflussen ergebnis über diesen
zeitraum von zehn jahren konnten den
fraglichen ländern jedoch kein
deutlicher zusammenhang zwischen den
gesetzlichen änderungen und den
prävalenz raten des cannabiskonsums
ermittelt werden mit anderen worten
legalisierung erhöht nicht zwangsläufig
den konsum die faktische legalisierung
in den niederlanden hat also tatsächlich
nicht dazu geführt dass die zahl der
konsumenten krass eskaliert wäre eine
weitere überraschende erkenntnis
zwischen 1979 und 1994 ist der konsum
harter drogen eingebrochen das könnte
ein hinweis dafür sein dass cannabis
nicht als einstiegsdroge für andere
stoffe dient wie manche befürchten und
an dieser stelle finde ich dass man auch
über alkohol als einstiegsdroge reden
sollte die niederlande haben allerdings
ein ganz anderes problem durch die
liberalisierung von cannabis bekommen
die abgabe von cannabis in coffeeshops
unter konsum werden toleriert handel und
anbau werden aber nicht von offiziellen
stellen übernommen das heißt coffee
shops dürfen gras an ihre klienten
abgeben woher das cannabis kriegen hat
der staat ab die geregelt und da kommen
die illegalen drogen dealer ins spiel
sie haben mittlerweile ein großes
netzwerk in den niederlanden aufgebaut
das den bedarf an cannabis deckt und
heute auch für andere drohungen wie etwa
kokain genutzt wird ganz anders ist die
lage in kanada dort ist der anbau handel
und konsum seit 2008 zehn nicht nur
geduldet sondern explizit erlaubt sie
werden schon bald ein system haben dass
unsere kinder vor cannabis schützt und
der organisierten kriminalität die
profite nimmt das ist großartig das ist
wie das ende der prohibition beim
alkoholverkauf cannabis jetzt das ist
ein moment von dem du deinen kindern
erzählen willst du warst dabei das ist
was für die geschichtsbücher
jetzt für mehr in hedgefonds doch auch
hier gibt es probleme mit dem
offiziellen handel von cannabis das land
hat es nicht geschafft schnell genug
offizielle stellen aufzubauen und den
bedarf an gras zu decken bis heute läuft
etwa nur die hälfte des gesamten
cannabis handels über offizielle
anbieter und verkäufer der rest wird
immer noch über den schwarzmarkt
abgewickelt und auch die usa von denen
ein so großer verbots impuls ausgehen
haben es mittlerweile in 18 stark
erlaubt cannabis zu konsumieren
doch der anbau kauf und verkauf sind
ganz unterschiedlich geregelt deswegen
mussten sich die amerikaner kreative
vertriebswege überlegen in washington
ist es zwar erlaubt cannabis zu besitzen
nicht dabei ist zu verkaufen was aber
geht ist es zu verschenken und wie das
genau funktioniert und wie so dass sogar
ein geschäftsmodell sein kann das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal an unternehmer
mag nutzt diese gesetzeslücke für seinen
online shop pink fox aus
wenn sie verliert was kaufen geben wir
ihnen gerne cannabis das solange sie 21
jahre oder älter sind wenn sie eine
mütze oder ein hemd oder einen pullover
kaufen etwas so einfaches wie eine maske
oder einen sportbeutel ein paar socken
dann haben sie anspruch auf cannabis
ein land das nicht nur den konsum von
cannabis sondern auch von härteren
drogen in einem schlag durch
liberalisierte heißt portugal als
ehemaliger drogen hat dort mit einer
hohen zahl abhängiger entschied sich die
regierung 2001 zu einem mutigen schritt
der besitz von 25 gramm marihuana
zehnten access 2 gramm kokain oder einem
gramm heroin gärten von da an nicht mehr
als straftat sondern nur noch als
ordnungswidrigkeit
seit 2001 gilt wenn die polizei drogen
konsumenten mit kleinen mengen erwischt
werden sie nicht etwa angezeigt sondern
zu einem aufklärungs termin gezwungen
mit dabei ein jurist ein psychologe und
ein sozialarbeiter nach dem gespräch
wird entschieden hat der betroffene eine
abhängigkeit risiko braucht er
psychologische hilfe oder unterstützung
vom sozialamt
eine maßnahme die sich die
ampelkoalition als vorbild nehmen könnte
denn nach einführung dieser regel gab es
in portugal mitunter weniger
gerichtsverfahren wegen drogendelikten
was wiederum gerichte und gefängnisse
entlastet hat der blick auf länder mit
einer liberalen drogenpolitik hat uns
gezeigt ganz einfach ist das mit der
legalisierung von cannabis nicht wenn
der staat kann als erlaubt muss auch
dafür sorgen können dass offizielle an
bord genug davon produzieren können dass
der jugendschutz auch wirklich
funktioniert und dass abhängige die
hilfe bekommen die sie brauchen aber
klar es auch mal löst ein problem nicht
indem man es verbietet die legalisierung
von cannabis unter der ampel regierung
könnte ein mutiger schritt in richtung
eines transparenteren und ehrlicheren
umgang mit drogen sein ich persönliche
den nicht gedacht das kann dann bis in
deutschland doch noch legalisiert wird
finde aber dass die pro argumente auch
die stärkeren sind und jetzt seid ihr
gefragt was ist eure meinung zu dem
thema findet ihr es gut dass cannabis
legalisiert wird oder er nicht schreibt
es nicht in die kommentare wenn ihr mehr
zum thema sehen wollt dann schaut euch
hier die diskussion über die
legalisierung von cannabis bei 310
fragen an und hier gibt es eine weitere
folge kontext mit meinem kollegen theo
koll und dem thema klima politik und
verlässlich und main kanal zu abonnieren